you
are here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes it's Friday happy Friday everybody
I'm so excited first we're gonna welcome
tonight's guest this guest scissors
she's guesting for two this Christmas
she's eating for two and shopping for
Blue Fox and Friends first co-host Carly
I'm So Pregnant chickens
he's so outspoken he leaves the libs
Broken Social scientists and YouTube
hosts Otep Jesus
she's so green she recycles all her hate
mail Fox News contributor code too
and finally Santa accused him of
blocking his airspace my massive
sidekick in the NWA World Heavyweight
Champion Tyrus
all right
all right before we get to some new
stories it's Friday so it's time for the
live pie eating contest with the
audience
nah I didn't miss joking it's time for
this
Greg's leftovers
um
yeah it's leftovers where I read the
jokes we didn't use this week and as
always it's my first time reading them
so here we go first off former federal
government official Sam Brinton has been
fired after multiple arrests for swiping
luggage at airports police say if you
recognize the close Brenton wore as your
own
get a new stylist oh my goodness
U.S senator elect John fetterman has a
cameo appearance in a new Netflix crime
drama starring Christian Bale to be
released next month during a grocery
store robbery fetterman plays the role
of stolen vegetable
[Applause]
terrible people
I'm ashamed of my audience the FDA has
approved a new pill that treats diabetes
in cats
it comes in a specially designed bottle
that's easier to push off the kitchen
counter
is that funny really yeah that's a
courtesy laugh courtesy laugh yeah like
that's what I'm here for you want to see
what we do to Riders
who write really bad jokes this is this
is what we do
I knew we'd have a bad joke
for some reason I could just keep
watching that I don't know why a 90 year
old woman finally graduated from college
71 years after first enrolling she says
she hasn't landed a job yet because her
first question in every interview is
where do you see yourself in five years
now she uh plans to spend the summer
backpacking Across The Villages
and she's especially thankful her
student loans were forgiven by President
Coolidge
a toilet used by John Lennon at a
mansion he shared with Yoko Ono will be
put on display at Liverpool Museum fans
are thrilled as it will remind them of
her music
that is so good although she is
underrated but that was funny
U.S scientists successfully created a
nuclear fusion reaction by heating a
Target to over 5 million degrees until
now of course the only thing to reach
that temperature was a McDonald's apple
pie
what's up with that
several U.S army soldiers are under
investigation after sexually explicit
photos of them appeared on social media
wearing bondage gear and dog masks and
if you want to see them simply do a
Google search for big black [ __ ] or
spaniels
yeah you just said it
the whale starring Brandon Brandon
Frazier as a 600 pound man earned the
biggest limited opening of the year in
New York and La this week it also earned
praise for being the first feature film
to be shot entirely in a Sizzler
is it it also earned a Golden Globe
nomination for best sweatpants
huh did we really need a follow-up joke
I don't know
let's watch some more whipping all right
in a new interview producer Ryan Murphy
says he stands by the Jeffrey Dahmer
series despite backlash over the show he
said his only regret is that he didn't
include a scene at Dahmer's favorite
restaurant Five Guys
that
that's funny
and finally my two favorite words
together a study finds that one minute
bursts of activity during daily tasks
could actually prolong your life and if
the study is true Jeffrey tubin will be
will live to be a thousand
foreign
all right before we get to a story we
also need to do this
Greg's Corrections and why
you should never ever doubt him again
[Music]
Wednesday night while discussing the
arrests of Sam bankman freed in the
Bahamas this happened
this is what I got from my sorcerer's
sources in the Bahamas that it was the
bahamians the Bahamian police
that arrested him because
Bohemian yeah wow you didn't know that
Bohemia
H
yeah oh it's Bahamian it's never been
that no one's ever said that okay okay
shut up everybody
[Laughter]
turns out
I was right and they were wrong
as verified by worldatlas.com quote the
citizens of the Bahamas are known as
bahamians not Bohemians bahamians in
conclusion I am the smartest man
don't die
all right finally on to some actual news
disclosing elon's location earned them a
seven-day vacation Elon Musk suspended
at least a half a dozen journalists
yesterday accusing them of violating
Twitter's rules against doxing
some of the accounts belong to reporters
who covered or tweeted about the battle
between Elon and a college freshman who
is tracking his private jet flights Elon
tweeting quote they posted my exact
real-time location basically
assassination coordinates in obvious
direct violation of Twitter terms of
service
seven day suspension for doxing some
time away from Twitter is good for the
soul
that's good
you remember that guy Keith olberman he
was the highest profile person to be
suspended meaning there were no high
profile people who were suspended
and that's all there is to it Carly you
know I feel like this we're like the
broadcasting version of the nativity
scene
why because you're like Mary with the
little baby yes I like that yes yes
would you be the Y would you be a wise
man I am
um no he's the borough
I like the dog at least you didn't say
ass
obviously the Little Drummer Boy
yeah so Carly uh yeah I am going to
defend uh Elon Musk in saying that this
was more about his family than it was
about policy what do you think okay so
he was mad because apparently he he was
doxed and then it wound up in a stalking
situation yeah
um so this is interesting also because I
believe that because these people have
been suspended you can't really see
exactly what they tweeted so it's like
hard to check uh but I think that if
they posted his location in real time
then they deserve to get suspended but
if they just posted an article about him
getting docs then you shouldn't get
suspended no yeah so there's a
difference there yeah the other thing I
want to say about Elon Musk though is he
has become the ultimate trump-like
figure on Twitter because he is trolling
everybody and making them lose their
minds and then you have all these people
who are tweeting that it will be their
last tweet and they are leaving Twitter
and it is positively hilarious well you
know what it is he's treating Twitter
like a rich guy treats a boat I got a
boat I'm gonna just drive around the the
bay so all my neighbors see it yep uh
look everybody look at this giant boat
big steering he's like Geraldo
and then and then it's like his Twitter
is his boat he's just driving the boat
around the harbor
you you're out of here tap I do think
that he was like he's basically going
okay if you know my locations you're
gonna know my family location that's
doxing so he kind of pulled the dad card
maybe what do you think
this is this is very murky wood as we're
dealing with here yeah who's the lady uh
our California handling the sandbagment
free thing that looks like James Brown
um Maxine Waters Maxine I'm glad I knew
that wow
how did I get that the hair the hair
yeah yeah yeah yeah good hair I mean the
past few years she goes around and she's
basically authorizing violence against
public officials etc etc
Communists are radicals and they have a
history of being radical and being
radicalized and we're starting to see
that manifest through the media in their
propaganda uh we're in Dangerous Waters
uh when I think about these journalists
the only punishment I can think of is
that whipping tape
he's the problem is they would probably
enjoy it they would probably enjoy it
yeah it does kind of appear in a way cat
hypocritical but is it really because I
mean doxing is always wrong that's
always part of the policy so him doing
it like if if it's in it it's always in
Twitter it's part of the rules well it
it is the definition of hypocritical
because he tweeted last month my
commitment to free speech extends even
to not Banning the account following my
plane even though it's a direct personal
safety risk so he said that and it's not
really doxing because it's public
information that's why it is murky as
you said because I don't know which musk
I'm supposed to comment on that musk or
this musk or now he's saying okay well
should I you know he posted a poll
should I unban them now or should I
unban them in seven days so it's not as
though they're being permanently
suspended uh doxing uh I don't know if
you can really call it that either
because this was publicly available
information I think that it would if
he's gonna say he can obviously do
whatever he wants if he's going to be a
free speech absolutist then you should
be allowing that but again if it's a
seven day suspension if he's going to go
back on it and he has the ability to
sort of change his mind after feedback I
think that in any case that that's a
good thing the thing I mean I would I
would I would quarrel with you mildly
over the idea of public information
because everything is almost public now
you can find out my phone number on 4th
fortunately
don't call me stop putting it out I know
okay before we before we start you are
so petty
[Music]
let me use it on Wednesday night he sat
in his little cabin going they said I
was wrong
sending emails out across the country to
get somebody to back him up yeah and in
my defense I didn't know that was what
you're talking about because I wasn't
listening
so he was just agreeing with Tyler I was
like Bohemian is a word and
but you know you are just
[ __ ] Petty
and you were just like the little
journalist yeah because being suspended
for Twitter for seven days
please don't make a ten like whatever
you do
that like the reason why he did it was
because it led to um somebody right
crazy stalking him I don't think if that
would have happened he probably would
have done but again
seven
days yeah that's a first world
punishment but my favorite is so my
favorite is the CEO of a company going
it it's it's pretty good if you just
take a seven day break yes
facetious for my product
anyways it's bad and horrible so you it
should be the best
to get away from seven days because why
come for do they keep coming back this
if you write this is my last tweet it
means this is not my last tweet it's
like Dad always talks about on Tyrus and
Tim when someone posts a picture of them
crying just so people will say you're so
brave
I don't know I will never tell our
viewers to take a week off from this
show they can't because I'm too greedy
I need to pay off that boat
I call it Geraldo so petty yeah it's
just Petty that's an Indian code SS
Petty
Bahamian
you'll never forget that you won't let
us hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else